I have the power of God and anime on my side.
OHHHHH
OH MY GOD
If she breathes
She's a THOT!
Get the F*ck outta my room I'm playing Minecraft
[Oh Boi]
[This gonna hurt]
*SLAP*
[OHH IT'S WALUIGI!]
[Masahiro Sakurai loves us]
*laughs*
*claps*
Welcome everybody to YouTube's show
Meme Review Everybody
*claps*
The show where I kill memes
Today of course, we're starting off with this smash meme.
Oh boi, Oh boi. This meme really took off.
Incredible
Well you know everyone that invested in this meme
Sell. Sell. Sell.
This meme officially reached it's peak.
It's not going any further
Trust me on this one
And specially as I'm about to review it.
You know it's gonna die [OH NO]
It's over before you smash meme.
It's been a good run though.
So let's go through some of my favorites
Oh, Bro
*DEATH*
It's gonna be August 25th everybody
It's gonna be lit.
Logang: Careful like not to disrespect the culture.
*ENDS UP DISRESPECTING THE CULTURE*
*WALLLLLMMMAAAARRTT*
JP: you gonna take the kid
JP: And you gonna kill him
[WTF PAKE JAUL. LOL]
KSI 2: August 25th you and I
KSI 2: August 25th
August 25th everybody.
Hey, it's the moderator
Yes
What's this gonna be
Who is it? It's Joe Wellard
Oh No
[You Cringe You Die]
Egg Paul confirmed. Wow
Tech n9ne Confirmed.
TMZ guy: Boxing, wrestling; what do you think about Logan Paul taking on KSI
Post Malone: Oh man, I think I'm gonna go
(xXxPostMelonxXx has left the lobby)
That's pretty good it's pretty good.
I like when they're themed you know, there's an anime version
There is a KSI versus Logan Paul version. Could there be a Pewdiepie version? That'd be pretty cool
Guardian of Libraries:
Hey...
Hey... Hey...
Guardian of Libraries:
Hey... Hey... This is Library
He must be a really strong character, I wonder what his special is?
Telling people off and then walking away.
(Mr Worldwide 🇯🇵)
"Dis is Raibarary"
What's wrong wit choo bro?
wut da hell
(Power level: 1)
(Power level: 2)
Oh he strong
(Power level: 3)
(Power level: 4)
That's a strong boi
(Power level: 9)
(Power level: 9000)
Yeah!
Ninja: Because I *Ligma* you
*Ligma stage 3*
Ninja: You shut up when I'm talking to you
Ninja: You shut your mouth!
Asian KSI: Shoot
Asian KSI: Shoot, Uh.. Uhh.. Uhhh
Asian KSI: L...
Asian KSI: L-Lemmy
Asian KSI: Let
Asian KSI: Let Me
Asian KSI: Lemmy give ya'll a little bit of shadow boxing
Asian KSI: For chr... [I have no clue what he's saying]
Asian KSI: You know what i'm sayin? [No.]
Asian KSI: For realz
Asian KSI: Doh
For reals, doh, is this getting old for you? I feel like it's getting it's getting a bit stale, isn't it?
Thot slayer: You ready to *demonetised* die?
Thot: No
Thot: No, I'm a bad  *demonetised*
Thot: You can't kill me
She's got an anti-kill spell on her.
Oh, yeah, there's a vine edition all bad Instagram comedians
*Arriving for the party after the failure of her CONt*
She's latina you guys heard about this?
*strange Instagram """comedian""" language*
I don't even know who that is.
Yes!
Piques: Hell no
Hell no, okay this meme gets a
*instant meme death*
Five
Five.
Five.∞
Because good memes never die.
All right, let's move on no more smash memes
Dude, how do you feel?
*Prodigy.exe started*
Some of these are so creative
OHHHHHHHHH!
OHHHHHHHHH! OHHHHHH!
OHHHHHHHHH! OHHHHHH! NO WAY!
RiGbY!
Rigby is confirmed for smash!
This meme gets a 10/10 everybody. The smash meme is officially complete
We need none more. Nothing. Stop. Stop. Stop stop
*Sweden "Sluta snälla", means "Stop it, Please"
All right guys, moving on
Pls tho, leave a like for Elkay LZO8.
If you're a fan of the Elkay LZO8
Please smash like on this video right now just for - we're doing a survey here in this channel. It's not sponsored
It's just a way for us to know how many people really out there likes the Elkay LZO8
Cuz you know a lot of girls be like I want that Elkay EZS8L single drinking fountain
Although me, personally, I'm more of an Elkay LZO8 kind of guy and I don't discriminate against anyone's else's preferences
I respect them too much to give my opinion about women
*he laughs at his own joke*
Just so we can be clear
Okay
'Leave a like for Elkay LMABF8, and then give a sub for an EZS8L' alright?
Wishing well: I wish to be irresistible to men. Poof! okay?
model ezs8...
Wait a minute.. Wait a minute. There's a stiCKEr,  it comes uP
*tdpraaa*
IT'S THE ETRUSCAN MEME
I knew it
It's the sAme mEme
*angry baby noises*
Leave a like guys if you enjoy an Etruscan 600-500 BC boar *clap*
This meme gets of course an Etruscan 600-500 BC rating
ba ding
Moving * on *
This meme, it's a little strangey dangey
Ohio man arrested for trying to have sex with a van
Hmm strange
NC man arrested for stealing 5 pounds of baby powder from CVS
Okay, alright, alright, ok, good, alright
Man kills his girlfriend, because they couldn't chase hoes together anymore
This is so sad. Alexa. Can we play when will I see you again?
*proceeds to sing a different song*
*alexa plays the song he actually requested*
That's not the right song u shmUCK
*pewds breaks alexa*
That's what you gEt Alexa
All these criminals in America and their headlines
You think what's behind their motive? What drives them to do these deeds? Well, there's nothing more
incomprehensible action than the Florida man
You heard about the Florida man? The Florida man dials 911 and demands a ride home to change his underwear
Florida strike one
The Florida man arrested for attempting to break into jail
Florida strikes two
A Florida man in jail after making a big to-do about missing a can of shrimp
Jason Laughman allegedly attacks Michael Earhart with sword over missing shrimp
Florida strikes thrEE
MY SHRIMP, MY SHRIMP
I'm from Florida
Excuse me, Florida, are you okay? What is happening in Florida? You think it ends there?
Florida man arrested for refusing to stop mbmbbbh (Christian channel) in Burger King
Great picture there, great picture you got there
This has to be my favorite Florida headline. It says
Florida man arrested for twisting 2-year-olds baby boy's nipple off
Florida strikes again
Badup (nipple removing sound)
What??? They just came off
I swear to God
I was just, barely touching. They just fell off.
You know what? I think I didn't even touch him.
The air breeze from my finger made them fall off
They were very sensitive nipples. Clearly, the nipples are at fault here.
All these crimes are not a joke, okay
I'm not trying to make light of any situation here
This is clearly very serious
BUT there's one man that I am willing to forgive completely
One man whose actions are above the legal system one
One Florida man kidnapped scientist to make his dog immortal
Ay you! Mr. Scientist. You're coming with me - We need to save this dog. Okay. All right
I'm not a veterinary, but I see what I ca-MAKE HIM IMMORTAL
I would do it for you, Edgar
Florida man meme gets a five five five
* *
Lip-syncing app Musical.ly has been killed off
What? Musical.ly has been shut down?
Alexa... This is so
AWESOME. Yay! *evil laughter and clapping*
Alexa: Hmm I don't know that on-
NO ONE ASKED
Who will I now go to watch cringey kids online
[why brad 3 why]
[we liked felix editing but now]
[i regret]
'Why do you have to keep being a furry a secret? Why you have to call it coming out when you tell someone you're a furry? Isn't it just a hobby?'
I want to die. Thank God. Thank God. I don't know how to rate this meme. I just, it's just cringey
* *
He is in anguish. He mourns.
What does monster have to mourn?
Alexa, this is actually
*burp*
...sad. He is in anguish. He mourns
What does this monster have to mourn?
Alex J-
* *
Meme review everybody
YouTube's
YouTube's YouTube
YouTube's YouTube YouTube
YouTube's YouTube YouTube YouTube
Thanks for watching and I'll see you tomorrow with another *laughs*
I'm here every day. YAY
What's he gonna upload next? LWIAY? Cool. Bye